bueno ahora que ya sabemos lo que es una
solución entonces vamos a pensar un poco
sobre qué es lo que se necesita para
obtener que una molécula sea soluble en
una solución o en un solvente así que
vamos a decir que comienzo con una sal
déjame ponerlo aquí con una sal ok y
bueno voy a decir que empiezo con la sal
pero lo estoy viendo desde una parte del
lenguaje diario es decir haré un poco de
lado esto porque en química escucharás
la palabra sal todo el tiempo en el
lenguaje diario la sal bueno es la sal
de mesa lo que hace que la comida sea
salada o el cloruro de sodio am n am ok
cl y esto a la vez es una sal desde el
punto de vista de un programa de
televisión de cocina hasta el punto de
vista de la química
esto es una sal en un lenguaje químico
aunque no le importe si está utilizadas
para sazonar la comida desde el punto de
vista químico la razón por qué es
llamado nasal es porque es un compuesto
neutro que está hecho con iones así que
todos sabemos qué es lo que pasa cuando
tomamos una sal cuando hablamos de una
sal y dejamos subir aquí a nuestra
la periódica bueno pues recuerda que
sucede lo siguiente el sodio
este que está acá quiere perder su un
electrón de valencia
su único electrón en su capa de valencia
mientras que el cloro bueno él y lo
tengo justo acá déjenme de verde color
el lo quiere tomar al cloro le encanta
esta idea ok y si ahora regresamos a
donde estábamos acá abajo ok a nuestra
sal bueno pues ahora nos dé cuenta que
va a pasar lo siguiente el cloro
déjame ponerlo con este mismo color se
convierte en un millón negativo mientras
que el sodio se convierte en un ión
positivo y esto hace que estos dos se
aferren muy fuertemente el uno al otro
porque bueno este ahora este positivo y
este ahora es el negativo después de que
se llevó su electrón no sé se me ocurre
en ejemplo imagina que tu casa es muy
pequeña así que tienes que regalar a tu
perro bueno a alguien que tiene un
jardín muy grande para él pero ahora
tienes que pasar el tiempo en la casa de
esa persona es decir de la persona a la
que le diste el perro porque tú quieres
mucho ese perro no sé si esta analogía
es del todo apropiada pero creo que ya
entendiste la idea
lassad simplemente es cualquier
compuesto que es neutral
los otros compuestos comunes no sé se me
ocurre a este bueno también está el
cloruro de potasio
cl esta es otra sal o por ejemplo se me
ocurre el bromuro de calcio es decir se
ha de r2 éstas también son sales y
existen un montón de ellas y ahora lo
que quiero pensar es en lo que va a
suceder si se intenta disolver estas
sales en agua pero lo que sí sabemos es
que es lo que pasa con el agua líquida
verdad si yo tomo agua líquida
imagínate que este es un oxígeno ok y
bueno también tenemos dos hidrógenos
estás de acuerdo a los hidrógenos son
como dos pequeños chipotes que salen por
aquí am se me ocurre poner uno por aquí
ok y voy a poner a otro por aquí ok aquí
tengo a mis dos hidrógenos y bueno
también puedo poner a otra molécula de
agua si yo tengo por ejemplo por aquí a
otro oxígeno bueno pues este otro
oxígeno am recuerda que tiene una cierta
orientación dos hidrógenos están
orientados bajo esta otra molécula del
agua
esto ya lo hemos visto varias veces en
otros vídeos así que se vería más o
menos así esta parte atrae a este a este
que es un hidrógeno y bueno por aquí
tengo al otro justo por aquí y techo
estos son los enlaces de hidrógeno
recuerdas son los que hemos hablado
mucho así que déjame ponerlos por aquí
tengo un cierto enlace ok y puede notar
la espora que tenga a otro oxígeno antes
de ponerlo por acá por aquí tengo a otro
oxígeno y entonces a darte cuenta que
aquí tengo también otro enlace antes de
poner por aquí a estos dos hidrógenos
por aquí tengo a uno de sus hidrógenos
por aquí tengo a otro de ellos y
entonces tenemos algunos enlaces justo
por ejemplo aquí tengo unos enlaces y
pues seguramente puedo poner a otro más
por aquí
ok seguramente te estás dando cuenta de
la estructura que forman aquí tengo a
otro oxígeno y bueno por aquí voy a
tener sus dos hidrógenos uno por aquí el
otro por acá ok
aquí tengo otros enlaces aquí tengo un
enlace aquí tengo otro de ellos ok y de
hecho si estuvieras en estado sólido
esto sería más o menos rígido y
solamente vibrar y anne en el lugar
en el estado líquido todo se está
moviendo alrededor se están frotando las
unas con las otras pero se están
quedando muy cerca en realidad para el
agua el estado líquido es el estado más
compacto y bueno cuando estás tratando
con cosas como esta donde se están
moviendo algo así alrededor ok se están
moviendo esto alrededor tal vez estos de
aquí se mueven en esta dirección no lo
sé y que es resolver algo como el
cloruro de sodio el cual sabemos que es
una molécula bastante grande y si nos
fijamos tratar la periódica de nuevo así
que déjeme subir la pantalla si
regresamos a nuestra tabla periódica que
es justo la que tengo aquí
bueno pues date cuenta de lo siguiente
justo por acá bien pues si te fijas aquí
el oxígeno es un elemento del periodo 2
y el hidrógeno es muy pero muy pero muy
pequeño sabemos que cuando hay un enlace
de hidrógeno con el oxígeno realmente
está un protón sentado por ahí porque
todos los electrones que deben pasar el
tiempo con el oxígeno y ahora lo que
quiero que veas es que el cloro tanto el
cloro como el sodio son mucho más
grandes no voy a entrar en dilemas de
tamaños moleculares pero sabemos que los
elementos
es más grandes a medida en que avanzamos
hacia la derecha en la tabla periódica
así que el cloro es mucho más grande que
el sodio y bueno sabemos que el tamaño
del cloro aumentó con la adición del
electrón que le quitó al sodio mientras
que el sodio positivo se hizo más
pequeño así que el ión de cloruro es
mucho más grande que el ión de sodio
pero ambos son más grandes que el
oxígeno y el de hidrógeno así que si
regreso a dibujarlos por acá en
regresamos aquí a nuestra idea de sales
ok ahora voy a dibujar a estos dos tanto
al sodio como al cloro justo aquí así
que si dibujo al sodio con este color ok
pues bueno se va a ver más o menos así
por aquí tengo al sodio que es un poco
más grande que bueno el oxígeno antes
que me pones lo que es el sodio que por
cierto tiene una carga positiva bien y
bueno por acá voy a dibujar con este
color al cloro al cloro que por cierto
es más grande que el sodio así que
déjenme dibujarlo justo por acá ok
aquí tengo muy claro que por cierto
tiene una carga negativa bien y ahora lo
que sucede cuando los pones en agua es
que los disocian a pesar de que cuando
estos chicos
están en estado sólido están compactados
unos con otros cuando los pones en agua
pues este camión del sodio este estudio
con carga positiva se va a sentir
atraído por la carga parcial negativa
del oxígeno por las cargas parciales
negativas del lado del oxígeno del agua
mientras que el cloro que tiene una
carga negativa se va a sentir atraído
por los hidrógenos a esta parte de aquí
se va a sentir atraído por esta parte de
acá pero con el fin de conseguir que
este guión de sodio no sé por ejemplo
entre aquí al agua bueno pues tiene que
encajar ahí así que por ejemplo dibuje
esto como un líquido inicialmente pero
si esto fuera un sólido y tuvieras esta
estructura será extremadamente difícil
el hecho de que éstos encajen aquí de
hecho sería casi imposible apretar estos
enormes iones de sodio o de cloro y
hacerlos solubles en hielo e incluso en
agua fría estos enlaces todavía van a
ser bastante fuertes si pensamos en el
agua muy fría y van a estar apenas
moviéndose más allá de ellas porque no
hay mucha energía cinética así que lo
que tienes que hacer es calentar el agua
primero quiero decir podrías
en el agua fría porque al menos el agua
fría tiene cierta elasticidad pero entre
más caliente tengamos el agua es mejor
porque tienes un poco de energía
cinética y eso esencialmente nos va a
dar espacio o va a dejar un poco de
espacio para que este guión de sodio y
este de cloro puedan chocar en su camino
con esta configuración que
razonablemente estable y bueno esto nos
lleva a pensar que ahora esto se va a
ver más o menos así dejemos subir un
poco la pantalla ok y ahora fíjate más o
menos cómo se va a comportar todo esto
déjeme atrapar esta parte de aquí ok la
voy a copiar y la voy a pegar porque
vamos a aplicarnos primero en qué es lo
que está sucediendo con nuestro sodio ok
lo tengo por aquí pero como el sodio es
positivo entonces va a traer al extremo
negativo de las moléculas del agua es
decir se va a ver más o menos así déjame
buscar el color y entonces ahora el agua
se va a ver más o menos así puedo tener
una por aquí aunque otra por aquí ok
otra por aquí ok otra por aquí ok tal
vez otra por acá
y lo que quiero que veas es que estos
son los extremos negativos
de esta molécula del agua y ahora los
extremos positivos es decir la parte de
los hidrógenos am se van a ver más o
menos así van a estar del otro lado o
dicho de otra manera van a estar
apuntando en la otra dirección
este también se va a ver más o menos así
ok esté más o menos así o algo así y
bueno esto es en el caso de que tengamos
a nuestro sodio pero si pensamos en el
cloro
bueno pues declaró también se va a ver
involucrado
de hecho el cloro am se va a ver más o
menos así déjenme atraparlo ok lo voy a
copiar y pegar ok y ahora lo tengo por
acá y bueno es que el cloro ahora se va
a sentir atraído por toda esta situación
que está pasando por aquí pero se va a
sentir atraído por la parte positiva de
estas moléculas y bueno con el fin de
obtener la mayor cantidad de cloruro de
sodio en nuestra muestra de agua bueno
debemos de calentar el agua tanto como
sea posible porque lo que va a pasar es
que estos enlaces de aquí no van a ser
tomados tan en cuenta y entonces estos
iones relativamente grandes
chocar en el camino de estas moléculas
del agua así que si en general piensa
sobre la solubilidad déjame ponerlo aquí
solo
y liquidada acerca de la solidad de un
soluto en agua o especialmente si
piensas en un soluto sólido en este caso
el cloruro de sodio en un solvente
líquido que en este caso es el agua
entonces a una temperatura más alta
mientras estés en estado líquido
vas a ser capaz de tener mayor cantidad
de sonido en el líquido o vas a aumentar
la solubilidad por así decirlo así que
déjame ponerlo si aumentas la
temperatura o que la temperatura sube ok
entonces la solubilidad también
y unidad también ok si por ejemplo
quisiera hacer este mismo experimento
tomando sal de mesa me parece que no es
algo demasiado peligroso ni demasiado
caro ya que bueno en general la sal es
relativamente barata y la advierte en un
vaso bueno pues en algún punto se
disolverán es más temen poner aquí a
nuestro paso ok y tú vas a advertir sal
en este vaso pero ahora quiero que te
des cuenta de algo si tú agitas la sal
entonces bueno puedes agitarlo para
asegurarte que se está disolviendo bien
pero inclusive te podrás preguntar qué
es lo que está pasando a nivel molecular
mientras lo estás agitando porque te
ayuda a la solubilidad el agitar las
cosas en fin aquí tenemos nuestro vaso
con agua y lo que quiero que veas es que
hay veces que la sal am se pone aquí
abajo en la parte de abajo justo por acá
de nuestro vaso es decir en algún punto
tendrás estos cristales ok en nuestra
parte de abajo de nuestro vaso y en este
caso estoy diciendo que el agua está
saturada con sal a la temperatura que
estás manejando
tú
nada si fueras por ejemplo ponerlo en el
microondas o si fueras a calentarlo
verás incluso que estos cristales de
aquí se pueden disolver en el agua y eso
es porque la energía cinética extra que
le estás metiendo es decir la
temperatura está haciendo que sea más
probable que estos de aquí estos enlaces
de aquí se rompan es decir es más
probable que estas moléculas sean
capaces de deslizarse fuera de la
configuración sólo por el tiempo
suficiente para que estos de aquí logren
chocar y bueno aquí quiero hacer una
pequeña nota cuando tomas estas sales
las cuales son compuestos iónicos
neutros es decir que están hechos con
iones pero que se anulan entre sí estas
sales en su estado sólido normalmente no
conducen electricidad aunque están
cargadas están muy pegadas entre sí de
tal forma que no hay espacio para el
movimiento de carga sin embargo una vez
que las disuelve en agua tienes cargas
flotantes y eso sí conduce la
electricidad así que esto se vuelve un
conductor de electricidad
ahora la regla general a la que estoy
tratando de llegar es justo este de aquí
esta de aquí esto es muy importante si
tratas con un sólido en un solvente
líquido bajar la temperatura disminuirá
la solubilidad porque es más difícil que
se aprieten las moléculas ahí y entonces
incrementar la temperatura aumentará la
solubilidad pero bueno ahora la pregunta
sería qué pasa con un gas o si quieres
hacer un refresco y bueno no sé dióxido
de carbono digamos en agua de nuevo y
solamente recuerda que cuando estamos
trabajando con sales que son compuestos
iónicos tienen alguna atracción natural
a los diferentes extremos polares de la
molécula del agua pero esos gases dos
gases en su mayoría de los casos no pasa
eso tenemos subir un poco a esta
pantalla cuando yo hablo acerca de un
gas que es lo que está pasando no tienen
fuerzas de atracción tan fuertes estás
de acuerdo es por eso que los gases
especialmente a temperatura ambiente les
gusta hacer
bueno pues nosotros sabemos que los
gases tienen un montón de energía
cinética amigos casas en general van uno
por acá otro por acá y es más lo más
importante entre ellos es que sus
enlaces son muy débiles es decir que si
yo me imagino aquí un enlace entre ellos
a este enlace va a ser muy débil e
inclusive los gases no les recuerdas
ellos sólo tienen fuerzas de dispersión
de london y tienen enlaces muy débiles y
es por eso que la misma temperatura y
presión el agua se de un líquido ellos
brincan lejos los unos del otro porque
no quieren tocarse entre sí pero bueno
mejor quite esto de tu cabeza ok vamos a
borrarlo y realmente de lo que quiero
que hablemos es de lo siguiente
imagínate que ahora todas estas
moléculas de guía está esta está esta
están son moléculas del agua ok tenemos
a un buen de moléculas del agua y cada
uno de estos círculos representa una
molécula y bueno yo lo que quiero hacer
es tomarme al dióxido de carbono ok lo
voy a poner con este color voy a tomarme
el dióxido de carbono y lo quiero lo voy
a intentar disolver en am aquí en el
agua así que por aquí tengo al dux yo
carbono por aquí tengo otra molécula
por aquí se me ocurre tener otra
molécula por acá tengo a otra molécula
de ellas es más por aquí antes de poner
otras más una por acá otra por acá si
quisiera disolver el dióxido de carbono
en el agua que quieren hacer estas
moléculas de morado que tengo aquí
recuerda que el estado natural del
dióxido de carbono es ser un gas a
presión estándar así que realmente lo
que va a querer es escapar del agua e
irse de aquí pero simplemente no puedo
hacerlo tan fácil porque hay moléculas
de agua alrededor estás de acuerdo este
chico de aquí este chico de aquí a me
encantaría desplazarse para afuera pero
no puede porque está rodeado por
moléculas uno por acá otro por acá por
moléculas del agua mi pregunta sería que
le ayudaría a desplazarse hacia afuera
bueno si aumentas de energía cinética
del sistema si tú aumentas en el
cinética del sistema entonces éste tal
vez si podría salirse de aquí si hiciste
que todas las moléculas del agua se
muevan más rápido bueno entonces es más
fácil que éste se salga y de hecho
especialmente si tú logras que también
las moléculas del dióxido de carbono
tengan más energía cinética entonces va
a ser mucho más fácil que salgan y bueno
una experiencia personal es que cuando
tienes un refresco en una
también puedes agitar el sistema porque
si agitas el sistema
mueves todo alrededor lo suficiente como
para que las moléculas de dióxido
carbono puedan escapar así que cuando
disuelve es un gas dentro de un solvente
líquido es decir cuando absoluto es un
gas en realidad tiene el efecto
contrario a lo que habíamos visto acá
arriba antes de ponerlo con este color
si tú aumentos de temperatura ok en este
caso si tú aumenta esa temperatura
entonces la solubilidad solubilidad va a
bajar la solubilidad va a bajar porque
estas moléculas bueno quieren escapar y
en fin quieren ser libres quieren estar
lejos de otras moléculas quieren rebotar
en un espacio abierto entonces todo lo
que le permite el sistema que se mueve
alrededor va a subir y de igual manera
si tú disminuye la temperatura
entonces la solubilidad va a aumentar y
bueno otro factor que no es un gran
factor y para eso déjeme bajar un poco
más esta pantalla si quiero pensar en un
último factor a estar aquí y esta vez
hablando de un soluto gaseoso es
la presión así que volvamos a pensar en
este misma idea si yo por aquí antes de
tomar este color tengo al dióxido
carbono o kate en dibujar tres moléculas
de dióxido de carbono diagrama am punto
un buen de moléculas del agua puede
poner por aquí moléculas la agua por acá
también ok muchas moléculas del agua ok
vamos a poner varias por aquí ok y ahora
imagínate que pienso en lo siguiente voy
a pensar en que ya se disolvieron y creo
que tienes la idea porque bueno las
moléculas no me quedaron del mismo
tamaño pero lo que quiero ver es lo
siguiente vamos a pensar en la presión
bueno lo que habíamos dicho es que las
moléculas del dióxido de carbono su
naturaleza es tratar de salir justo de
aquí es estar libremente es decir ellas
intentan de alguna forma escapar de aquí
pero si tienes una presión realmente
alta aquí arriba vamos a hablar de la
presión
imagínate que tenemos una presión de la
atmósfera aquí donde tenemos un montón
un montón de moléculas que están
empujando lo más que puedan a esta
superficie de nuestra solución
bueno pues qué crees que vaya a pasar lo
que pasa es que
estas moléculas del dióxido de carbono
va a ser mucho más difícil que escapen y
es por esto que cuando la presión sube
déjame ponerlo así cuando la presión
sube ok entonces aunque crees que va a
pasar la solubilidad solubilidad ok
vibilidad esta va a aumentar también y
bueno aquí estamos hablando del caso de
un gas cuando tenemos que la presión
aumenta la solubilidad del gas también
sube en fin así que lo interesante lo
que quiero que recuerdes es justo esto
si yo am déjeme rezar para acá arriba si
yo hablo de un sólido a este sólido ok y
aumentó la temperatura entonces qué es
lo que va a pasar bueno se aumentó la
temperatura para disolver un sólido en
mi soluto líquido entonces esta va a ser
que tenga una mayor solubilidad es justo
lo que dice aquí la temperatura es buena
para la solubilidad del sólido cierto
dijimos que cuando pones sal o azúcar en
agua es bueno incrementar la temperatura
y entonces serías capaz de meter más sal
o más azúcar pero por otra parte en los
gases pasa completamente lo opuesto
déjame bajar ahora
porque la pantalla siguió bajo en la
pantalla justo que vimos aquí que la
temperatura disminuye la solubilidad o
dicho otra manera
queremos temperaturas más frías para
poner más grasa en la solución o bueno
si nosotros pensamos en presión lo que
vamos a querer es una mayor presión ok
para poder poner más gas en nuestra
solución es decir para que menos
moléculas puedan escapar por la parte
superior o bueno al menos esa es la
forma en la que me imagino todo esto
pero espero que todo esto le des
encontrado muy útil porque aquí acaba el
vídeo